Mary here with a gamespot news update if
you haven't had your fill of the witcher
3 yet you're in luck because another big
patch is on its way developer CD Projekt
RED on friday announced the 1.08 patch
for the open-world role-playing game
which makes changes and improvements in
the areas of performance you I gameplay
graphics and more the patch should
arrive quite soon the developer says in
the games forum specifically this patch
adds the preparatory features for the
witcher 3 upcoming new game plus mode it
also clears up an aggravating
achievements issue on PC and adds
functionality to allow garel to perform
a role just before landing to reduce
fall damage also heads chopped off
during finishers don't disappear and
various fixes two quests have been
implemented the patch will also add a
new potion called wolven hour which
reduces the level requirement for all
gear for an hour for a full list of
changes be sure to check out the patch
notes on gamespot com patch 107 rolled
out a few weeks ago and featured a
number of substantial changes and tweaks
unfortunately the update did hurt the
game conformance on consoles but this
new update aims to correct those issues
hopefully we'll be seeing that update in
the next couple of weeks for everything
The Witcher 3 stay tuned to gamespot com
you